un moment simple plein d'émotion parce
que la président du conseil
départemental remis l'insigne de
chevalier de l'ordre national du mérite
à roger lavergne
pour comprendre cet illustre personnage
nous nous rendons chez lui des livres
partout
il faut dire que cet ancien professeur a
très vite partagé ses connaissances
quatre ou cinq feuilles de femmes
accusées dix minutes dans une tasse
d'eau bouillante soigne la grippe
informations apportées par l'élève
nicolas imbert de 5e b
en fait je suis né à la mûre qui est un
petit village sur la route napoléon
c'est là où il y avait des des mines
d'un principe c'est là où mon père a
travaillé toute mon enfance j'ai vu papa
revenir de la mine
il était plus noir que le plus noir des
cafres et eu un poste au collège
juliette dodu
écoutez bien en taïwan parce qu'on
connaît très bien où se situe la réunion
et bien au ministère
une immense biographie consacrée aux
plantes réunionnaise constitue son
oeuvre la plus célèbre d'entre elles est
en fleur de bourbon littérature initié à
une époque où ce n'était pas à la mode
la pratique était simplement culturel
c'est donc à l'espace réglée du bas de
la rivière saint denis que cette
cérémonie a eu lieu
et dès l'arrivée des invités c'est eux
qui se font photographier pourquoi vous
faites des photos des autres alors c'est
vous qui est à l'honneur mais c'est pour
faire un diaporama
parce qu'un principe hostile les gens
qui sont là ce sont mes invités ce sont
des amis c'était un homme de science et
même de grandes connaissances un grand
tort ou la grandeur n'a de mérite
également que de sa grande humilité
devant toutes ces connaissances
extraordinaire agressé l'ethnobotanique
au crédit sinal donc il ya dix ans il y
en a pas beaucoup survivent à ça il a
passé son doctorat
quand il était enseignant dont il a
toujours fait ça en peluche est ce que
moi j'apprécie beaucoup avec roger c'est
que il va toujours au fond des choses
mais pour en arriver là dossier a été
nécessaire à monter une initiative
collective scolaire roger bien sûr mais
peut-être pas suffisamment pour pouvoir
monter un dossier c'est pour ça que je
me suis adressé à quelqu'un qu'il
connaît bien
à savoir son fils christophe et avec lui
va écouter on a travaillé et ça a bien
duré une année quand même il faut quand
même retracé un petit peu tout ce qu'il
a fait j'étais peut-être le mieux placé
pour remplir un dossier mais je savais
pas tout il ya quand même des choses que
j'ai découvert donc il a fallu chercher
souvent il fallait avoir des réseaux et
que parfois des personnes très méritante
pouvait y échapper
parce que n'avait pas les entrées
nécessaire il faut être parrainé et donc
depuis cinq ans nous montons des
dossiers nous aidons les gens à en
constituer et c'est là qu'on voit que et
réunionnais celui qui aime la terre
réunionnaise et qui est habité par la
bri lyonnaise roger laden est un grand
rire
il y en a plein comme lui mais lui c'est
un grand et honorer le travail qu'ils
ont fait on aurait aussi l'identité de
ces personnes avec l'amour des plans de
la connaissance de la poésie du petit
comme de la grande vision de notre
territoire en présence de tous les amis
de ta famille nous vous faisons
chevalier de l'ordre national du mérite
avec nos félicitations
des générations entières de collégiens
ont fait les herbiers de monsieur
lavergne six mois les passionnés de
botanique aujourd'hui c'est quand même
grâce à lee il a des moyens ni la
brillante à moins que dans toutes les
associations la réunion et il peut dire
qu'aujourd'hui 6 me à prendre et me
transmettre mon savoir avec mon band
jeune guide aujourd'hui c'est quand même
grâce à roger
nous y sommes on a tous aux collections
mais à suivre les sentiers damés une
nounou de temps en temps aussi pour la
reconnaissance des plantes dont médias
c'est mon père spirituel
je suis étonné par la grâce qui me fut
donné d'avoir un style souple et fleurie
inverti l'imaginaire
j'aime faire chanter les mots avoir le
verbe enchanteur je ne peux qu'être fier
d'être devenu un écrivain naturaliste
qui continuent à inscrire son oeuvre au
souffle du patrimoine réunionnais
l'écrit par passion et puis ça vient
tout seul on peut pas l'en empêcher
d'ailleurs pas si c'est impossible
ces derniers temps et il n'a pas arrêté
d'écrire en sourire la santé est fragile
la conclusion sera pour cet homme qui ne
peut s'arrêter de partager comme je les
vis à nassimah et devant tout le monde
ce qu'on donne fleury second garde
pourri c'est ça que tu veut complet gens
retiennent bris